and sanders so i know you've written and
thought a bit about storytelling so
i just would love to ask you more about
your thoughts about
what the role what the role is for
storytelling uh when it comes to
what we're looking at going forward
because we have not just this pandemic
but obviously other
uh predictable but long interval events
to think about for the long run
indeed i mean i think i mean
storytelling is um is both our oldest
and our best technology and we
um for this type of stuff i mean even um
you know even the written word
um well it's been around for thousands
of years um
in a it's still difficult to pass on in
many cases and
um as i think danny hillis put it you
know thousands of years ago we wrote
things on
on in stone that last thousands of years
hundreds of years ago we wrote things in
in paper that last hundreds of years now
we're doing things in computers which
kind of is
five years or whenever you swap your
computer out whichever comes first
um and um so our storytelling
capabilities um are
well they have some of the best tools
they've ever had in video and film and
and things like that they're also um
they're also not ideal for
kind of campfire telling of stories from
generation to generation and
i do think actually um you know on this
front one of the things that helped
uh even our present um situation was the
the really amazing movie contagion that
was done um
and that was you know that was funded by
um real science uh
real science driven effort from the um
the school global threats fund
um and um and amazing people consulted
on it that had been part of real
um outbreaks and were part of those
teams to solve them and so
and they did that they they used
science-driven
storytelling with you know first-run
movie actors in production
to tell a story that i think is you know
it's now one of the most watched
streamed things you know right after
tiger king um but it's
it's one of the most streamed uh movies
right now and i think it's been actually
truly i mean the amount of parallels in
that movie to what we're going through
are insane it's so good um and i think
it's really helped
even though it it may not have changed
too many
people's preparation habits it certainly
has helped them
deal with the the present moment which i
think is
is pretty key for sure